last week we have spoken you just touch
very quickly we've spoken about ideas
how to attack the king after he is
castle with squares a week usually the
squares just around the king and how to
get to them today I want to touch
something that has direct connection to
forcing moves basically the hour forcing
moves only that we call them tiny bit
different because they appear in a
position we will we will call them
intermediate moves in many different
positions what are intermediate moves I
already told you they have to be four
singles but what are they well what's
the purpose of playing an intermediate
move at all anyone knows what what does
intermediate means at all if I show you
this position who do you think is to
play here white or black why to play
here why do you think white is to play
here would I show you this position if
you try to play I don't think so why
wouldn't it be why to play because white
will just take black screen right so
naturally I mean yeah maybe but I I
think highly of you all of you so I'm
not going to show your position of night
x screen right maybe a year ago two
years ago not today so it's black to
play I can tell you the blacks normal
move logical move ok let just can play
this move everyone's happy the game will
be a draw but my question eat what
happens if black is going to play Queen
takes Queen dramatic yes what then
you want to tell me what will replay
which right there if the Queen takes the
Queen what will you play with right now
okay so you say the pawn will take the
queen bee okay do we have anything else
to play yes but ah with what that's what
I because I was going to ask you hey I
took your queen you want to take Abby
shop that sounds horrible move but then
you said with a check this is exactly
what is intermediate move look black is
going to play well if black plays this
which is a really bad white can say okay
I can take back then we just did what
two traded Queens but white can also say
you know what before i'm going to take
back before I have something else to
play that's the idea of intermediate
somewhere in the middle in the middle of
a sequence you know you take I take you
take I take but in the middle I want to
play something and that something for
example is check what is black gonna
play here here's one move to play right
do we all see this one move
and then white is going to play so is
this tiny bit better for white because
white exchange Queens but managed to
also get a bit shocked so why did i get
the bishop because it played something
in the middle something in between in
chest you know you will call them either
intermediate or in between moves between
the theories of captures whitehead this
move a question for intermediate moves
to be successful do they have to be
really powerful and forcing or not now
so for example if this was not a check
wouldn't black movie skin in screen
wouldn't black movie screen if this was
not a check so it has to be something
that the opponent cannot do that it has
to be something very thank you it has to
be something very posting the queen is
hanging up in the air and you say hey
wait a second I want to play something
and then I'm going to exactly so
basically you are like putting the Queen
on a hold like a view of you you watch
DVD like some DVDs right you have the
pause button stop the movie basically
this is kind of like pause pause let me
do what I want then I'll get to do that
sometimes intermediate moves can be used
for other purposes for example they will
allow us to change something in the
position for example I'm going to be as
quiet as possible I want to think if we
have and I want to see if two three more
hands you will obviously answer first if
you like but I want to see two three
more hands white 2y to play here what
should I play him
new one answer okay you just found
something do what answer okay
so you want Bishop take Bishop right
okay what would likely after Bishop take
Bishop a black will capture back right
but did you gain anything that captures
back we just traded right okay then
which we tried it you took a big shop
you gave a bishop right okay I think
white is something more than this in the
position you want to tell me c3 285 that
would be a free night if not what would
the opponent play let's see I want you
think think for a minute think to a
minute and tell me if you'll be shop
move to a five what will black play
would black Bishop be attacking the
Queen right so you want to take the
night that is not protected but the
Queen will be under attack right ok so
that's tiny bit where other ideas is
getting so what we play I want to see
more hands and then we'll see hope
you'll answer maybe now no problem ok do
you want to tell me
why why do you want to play go into f1
check and if neck is going to move watch
what happens then what then that's
actually the right move but why if you
tell me the right move without a purpose
without the reason I don't know so what
are you achieving biquini flood the king
is going to move and then how do you
want to tell me and what have you
achieved with Queen f1 what have you
achieved but yes you want in you win
denied but why why why now you can take
it because you managed to get the Queen
away yeah you manage to get the Queen
away from being under attack basically
you manage to allow the Queen let's
think about it in this way you tell
yourself I have a free night then you
tell us of my queen is under attack and
then you say hey if I can make my queen
go away from that square without
allowing my opponent to move the night
that's the key part without allowing my
opponent to move the night then I'm
going to win it but in order to do that
your move has to be check or extremely
extremely forcing move for example if
you are platinum checkmate on this side
of the board maybe it's also very
forcing but check by definition by rules
of the game is the most forcing most
forcing move let's see if we can have
tiny bit complicated positions ok that
will involve intermediate moves let's
see if we can we can make some of those
work this is our beautiful position and
it's right to play and it's a bit tricky
position
we have to see tiny bit to move the head
in this position that's if we can make
it happen I know this is I just want to
see if we can do it if not we will have
puzzles that are tiny less difficult why
do you play here
yes
yes but are you forcing anything that
will just play worked a clue you will
play Knight a cloak okay just exchanging
yes see one the book isn't see one right
but it will be okay so you want to move
the roof okay but they look actually is
not under attack because it's defended
right so we do not have to worry about
it because the work is pretty much
defended yes okay and what is so special
about those moves but but i have a
question at all actually it is black
threatening anything let's say it's
black straight is black gonna win
something the black is going to win mark
why is not going to win a walk you can
take them but isn't the rukon see one
defendant yeah no no no so first thing
first thing we have to make a list what
under attack what's defended if not we
are not understanding we are not you
know having a clear vision of the
position so black is threatening nothing
first of all let's first establish that
because everyone want to move the
roadblock take take nothing happen yes
before but if you will play before first
of all black who can just take it right
so we exchange did you get something ok
give me said tell me something that I am
getting something yes work takes night
ok now we are speaking but wait work
takes night if the poem if the Pawn will
take your work
then you take the other book no no we
because we are speaking really about the
right position right now that's actually
most importantly last three minutes
we'll just you know playing around Luke
take night okay so if the phone will
take the book we have a playbook takes
rook what what will you play if the rook
takes the walk-on see one but then it
will take you let's try to imagine the
position without moving the pieces we
will move the pieces in a second but if
we want to get better well we have to
bring kefir to vision how the position
will look without moving the pieces so
we will play woke Luke takes night and
he will play rook takes rook and if we
will take he will take our work and
which pieces will be left on the board
white will have a night left on c1 and
black will have a look left on a five
white cloth material but actually yes rd
what will take
check but the black king will move up
let's see I believe that this is the
right move but why wife is up three
points of material right okay but black
is not going to take the rook and allow
why to take the rook black will play
rook takes work ok so now actually black
is tiny bit of material right black to
which move now we're going to play yes
so now you're going to play work there
and what is work the egg what type of
move is it in the middle of this
sequence of capturing not take because
our work will take but we can actually
make something amazing we can like click
on pause wait don't move telling this
route don't move but I want to make my
book move right I want to make my work
move to da check black will have to play
one move and then we will take
this is exactly exactly what is the idea
of forcing moves most of them are used
like in that in a sequence to be able to
say the peace or to move a piece when
the main objective is like pretty much
all tactics tinctures but what's the
main objective in tactics in chess adi
all those tactics in combination what is
the main objective to do what forcing
and while what we want to do with them
we win win material exactly you know
nobody ever said he'll play ten forcing
moves while amazing game I want it no
say oh I play this tiny combination i
won in night and I want the game right
we want some material ok this is a bit
difficult one whites to play here let's
see if we have it's it's a two moves
idea not 11 move might be easy but it's
a two moves idea let's see if we can see
that cake you want to tell me work takes
t6 and if black will take the queen with
a screen you will play work take here
let me play Queen takes Queen what will
you play
but then I will take your work right
actually the move you suggested is not
bad it's the second best move in the
position but there's a better one
because the move that you played is
actually winning upon yes works is 71 in
the continuation dedicates adjusted when
works is seven come and show me do do
you have an idea because actually it's a
good move i think work takes c6 ok k
it's idea Queen takes Queen and now Roxy
7 I thought that's what you meant and
intermediate check that's what you meant
right I thought so because so you win a
pawn right that why i said Kate's idea
was the second best one and if the Queen
goes back to defend you just take it any
57 you just check and finally you in a
pot but there's a better way there is a
better way here
there's a better way what's a better way
for y to play exactly the same idea just
better yes rd the group would take the
bishop because well once i have the idea
why would I why would I be happy winning
one point if I can win three pawns right
the queen is not protected so the Queen
has to oh well either move but then you
lost the bishop and now what will we
play yes exactly what we will play
exactly exactly exactly what we will
play and pretty much pretty much winning
a piece in winning the game ok so we
have seen those idea bless you we have
seen those ideas s ideas for winning
material but sometimes they can be also
very important in helping us not lose
material for example let's look at this
position it is it's blacks to play here
black to play here not like black to
play here they can someone see an
interesting idea for Black Hill
two hands that has to be a good idea
okay well what's your idea would you
like Queen takes Knight now second
question is this a good okay but now
it's second question is this a good move
or not winning a night okay how about we
think again I can tell you it's not
winning a night but maybe now you can
tell me why why is it not winning a
knife because you know that this is
really really important before we have
seen intermediate moves with the idea of
for us to win material we will take
something the opponent will do something
okay we'll move that piece with a check
hey we capture this we will then take if
whatever piece that we exchange we want
something excellent but sometimes many
times looking at our possibilities for
us or for the opponent will be able to
save us form losing material for example
slowly if Queen takes Knight what will
happen if you just takes your queen will
take your screen so now let me ask you
this question does white have a way to
move his queen in a forced way after you
took the night because if white has a
way to movie screen in a forced way
after you take the night maybe you're
going to lose your queen you see all
right ad is about to explode sorry what
two letters
we go to 86 Queen takes the night then
Queen goes to 86th check check check
the King the king will move somewhere
and then you finally get to take the
Queen that is exactly exactly exactly
the idea exactly take take the Queen so
seeing an intermediate move actually
it's not winning material for us but it
is what preventing a storm blundering
the Queen right let's do one more
position like this very similar ideas
okay first question do we see why does
the pretty idea here I'm not saying it's
a strong idea but why does a pretty idea
in this position do we see any idea for
white
I'll see one Norman effect that if we
someone can spot this idea it's not a
simple one
oh sorry thank you coin to take the
dishes and then the dishes and say that
Queen takes the bishop okay that's
actually a very interesting idea but
what and what do you want to play if the
Pawn will take your queen issue come
show me because because that's the right
idea i just want to understand the next
move Queen takes bishop okay excellent
the pawn is going to take your queen
what will you play now
the move that maybe you're thinking is
to play this move that's an excellent
idea d phi check you can see then i will
explain it that this is very interesting
idea what is this check it is how do we
call in chess this type of check
discovered check because the bishop was
it change actually should be probably
uncovered check but the bishop is now
threatening check and actually the pawn
is attacking the Queen so what is going
to win material why took a big shop why
took a big shop and now let black hat
black and block but the Queen will be
captured for free or black and movies
King and then the Queen will be captured
but
you
now my question is what my question it's
Quinn take Bishop a good move or not I
can actually tell you it's not but why
because it looks brilliant right
taketake giving the Queen check all
along and winning black screen but it's
not
that's not going to have work you want
to tell me no you want to tell me oh no
no no just beautiful hair I didn't know
if it's raising the hand of playing with
your hair the book is on the D file so
why is this a wrong move it is actually
tell me show me show me show me show me
show me so ok take because the Queen
will come here and what would this check
be an intermediate will right before we
going to capture the Queen we're going
to tell him wait wait let me move my
queen from e6 let me move it somewhere
either I can I don't have anything that
I specifically care about history if
white king must heal you would come and
tell me hey Ronen I want to move my
queen to wear best exactly basically you
want to tell me anywhere I can move my
queen in the first way getting it away
from the discover check I'm going to do
it right exactly and then does it matter
how white face the check we're going to
take the Queen and check those exactly
nothing so what's the importance of
intermediate move they are forcing very
very focusing most of them are checks or
big captures and they can change well
pieces are for example in the position
that we had Queen takes Knight seems
like a very smart using the pin right if
white has a false way previous position
to move its Queen with a check black
lost a screen in this position why it
has a very smart idea i will give my
queen for a beer shop but then i will
take the Queen for free wait first the
queen is moving and then
taking the Queen
Oh